hello everyone the name's peak bradley
peak
and today i'm going to talk to you about
how to delete your personal data
this includes clearing out your social
media accounts and removing any traces
of yourself from data brokers
we'll also be getting into a debate that
has significant consequences for the
online world
that is the debate between american
style free speech
and europe's right to be forgotten are
you ready to explore the online jungle
with us
q get the aston martin
today information tends to be stored in
various networks and clouds
so even if i drown my laptop my photos
and my music will still be intact
this is because anything that i upload
to the network stays there forever
forever forever forever
now this is a really fun piece of kit
take a look at the wayback machine
this is effectively a non-profit
organization that functions as an
archive
for the internet if you want to see what
your favorite website looked like
say 10 or 15 years back well the wayback
machine
might be just for you but a tool like
this
really isn't just for fun for instance
digging into a website's past
could actually provide valuable
information for potential investors for
instance
on a company or a product now at the
same time having access to the
internet's past
can actually have some pretty serious
consequences for people's careers and
reputations
one example of this is adeline lafourin
a woman who
regularly posted suggestive photos of
herself online
no big deal right well adeline actually
worked as a secretary in the swiss
parliament
and one day her boss came across these
old pictures accidentally
and a subsequent scandal ensued and
unfortunately
adeline was actually forced to leave her
job as a result
of course this case got massive
attention from journalists and many
denizens of the internet so much so that
adeline
was actually soon very much on her way
to becoming a successful porn star
which i think she is today let's try an
experiment i'm actually now going to
google myself to see
what i can actually find out about
myself
now i'm going to be using incognito mode
so that my previous searches don't
actually affect the results
so for now let's try my first and last
name
[Music]
right so it appears i am essentially a
collection of sports jackets
let's try this again but this time i'm
going to remove the clothing
manufacturer from the results
now i can cross it out like this
and now it seems i'll have to do the
same with a few mountain tops in
wyoming and colorado
shouldn't be a problem
so now we've pretty much got what we
need i mean here you can see my youtube
channel
a link to my private instagram profile
my linkedin and some other irrelevant
stuff
of course now since i haven't ever
caught the attention of the media
you can find most of the information
about myself on social networks
on twitter facebook linkedin and the
like
but let's take a look at how you can
actually delete these
social media accounts
so if you'd like to protect yourself
from your past mistakes
i recommend actually deleting first of
all any unused accounts
and second of all thoroughly cleaning
out the ones that you do use
there's a bit of a problem here and that
is that deleting profiles on social
networks is not
as easy as it might seem at first now
this has to do with the purpose and
structure of these services
after all there's a reason why these are
called social networks
because across these networks like
countless data
on people places companies and other
organizations
and this data cannot fit onto one server
and that's why it's effectively spread
across the world via this
network also social networks provide
many different types of services which
means they tend to gather
this data and store it very differently
so even if you delete your facebook
profile
your previous comments or chat history
may still be
visible you watch bro what are you
talking about man
facebook to delete or to deactivate
that is the question whether tis nobler
in the mind to suffer
the slings and arrows of outrageous
comments
okay let's start with facebook there are
two ways you can get yourself off of
this site
you've obviously got deactivation or
deletion
now deactivation on the one hand lets
you hide your name your pictures
and other personal information from
public view but
luckily it allows you to continue using
messenger moreover you'll still be able
to log
into other services using facebook as
well and plus you'll be able to
reactivate your account
at any time should you wish to do so now
deleting your data on the other hand is
more of a radical step
and doing so does indeed result in the
permanent removal of your personal data
it also prevents you from using
messenger or even logging into different
services using facebook
now if you do decide to do this your
request is firstly sent to the facebook
moderators
and during the first 30 days you
actually have the option to reactivate
your account
by simply logging into it however if you
are
confident in your decision it can
actually take up to 90 days for all of
your personal data
to be removed from their system even so
facebook will actually maintain certain
information about your past activity
but only law enforcement will have
access to it
so if you're trying to cover up a
serious crime
by deleting your facebook profile this
probably won't help
so let's move on to instagram this is
really a lot like facebook i mean
unsurprisingly they're both owned by the
same company
and as such you have the same two
options deactivation
or deletion and if we're talking about
deletion it takes about
90 days for all of that data to be
deleted now similarly
law enforcement will still have access
to information if needed
so if you're trying to get away from a
crime that you committed deleting your
social media probably won't help
however if you want to hide from your
online past
from say job recruiters it should be
enough to just
temporarily deactivate your accounts
they won't have access to the
information
so let's move on to twitter and linkedin
now these
differ from facebook and instagram in
that the deactivation actually results
in the permanent deletion
if it lasts for longer than 30 days this
means that if you deactivate your
twitter account
you only have 30 days to log back in and
if you don't then your information will
be erased
and your twitter handle will be up for
grabs now linkedin functions just like
twitter with its
close account feature out of all of
these networks twitter is the only one
that warns users that their previous
activity may still be visible
on search engines even after deleting
their account
for instance google is able to show the
deleted tweets of deleted users
and to delete those tweets you'd
actually have to submit a request to
google not to twitter
[Music]
now when it comes to deleting
information that was previously
available online there's really a
raging debate and this debate relates to
the right to be forgotten now the
question here is whether a person can
request the factual information about
themselves
be deleted from search engines now
america and europe
have very different answers to this very
question
so let's talk about information brokers
and the first amendment now the first
amendment to the american constitution
as we all know protects the freedom of
speech
this means that the right to publish
factual information on the internet
trumps both
privacy and individuals right to
confidentiality
so if information is factual no one
really has
the right to request the removal of it
so
if you're looking for information on u.s
citizens there are plenty of big name
data brokers that will help you
i mean like spokeo fradaris and white
pages to name but a few
now i actually entered my name into
spokeo
and i found 18 individuals who share
i wasn't on the right page say so
i actually entered my name
into spokyo
and i found 18 individuals who share my
name living in the u.s
and you'll see here to get information
on these individuals it would actually
cost less than a dollar
and i wouldn't just be able to get their
phone numbers i'd actually also get
their emails
details on their families previous
addresses and so on pretty scary right
you're right it's fact i also checked a
few other american databases
and radaris also found some information
on 18
american bradley peaks just like me
right you're right again yes it was
you're right you were right now you'll
actually see here
i must say the details theodores
provides are quite impressive
aside from what you'd find elsewhere
radar tells you about bankruptcies
marriages divorces
criminal records and even about people's
neighbors i think
companies like this are called data
brokers
right or db for short and they've been
around for a long time
and i'm talking long before the dawn of
the internet i mean even as far as
far back as the 1950s they began
collecting information on people's
credit histories
and then scoring them as such they then
unsurprisingly went on to monetize this
information
today data brokers are collecting
information in a different way
they're instead taking the information
from social networks media
and other public sources of information
as a result they maintain
detailed dossiers on 230 million
americans
and over 10 percent of the world's
population
what is this data doing well it's
actually used for locating people
sociological and statistical research
marketing i mean even for targeted ads
as we all know
and much much more and moreover this
business is totally legal
in the us there have even been
discussions about regulating this sector
but
unfortunately no concrete steps have
been taken thus far
but there is good news you can in fact
delete yourself
from the records of these so-called
information brokers
now the easiest way to do this is
through services that actually
specialize in
deleting your personal data but they do
cost a buck or two so if you don't want
to pay for this
you can use what's called the free diy
opt out guide
on delete me but in this case be
prepared to spend quite some time on it
since you will have to actually fill out
each individual form for each individual
broker
now in europe thankfully personal data
protection is much better
and for this we actually have to thank a
man by the name of mario costeka
gonzalez
now in 1998 mario ran in some serious
financial problems and his home was
temporarily repossessed
now a local newspaper published a 36
word article on the mata
and over a decade later mary actually
filed to have the article removed
from google forever so in this case mary
argued that the old article negatively
impacted
on his business reputation which is fair
enough now legal proceedings dragged on
for
four years eventually resulting in
mario's victory so what did mario get
out of this
well the article remained on the website
of the newspaper
but it was actually deleted from the
google search engine in spain
which was incredible now mario's victory
formed the basis for europe's
right to be forgotten and even the day
that mario's court victory went public
12 000 europeans filed similar requests
to google
asking for their personal data to be
removed and soon enough google actually
introduced a functionality
that allowed exactly this now if you
live in the european union and you'd
like to delete yourself from google
searches
you can follow the link in the
description below of course
it can be argued that the right to be
forgotten may go against the interests
of society
for instance the same mechanism could be
used by dangerous people such as
i don't know convicted pedophiles or
scammers to actually hide
a history that could be incriminating
however
this right does not extend the public
lives of politicians i mean otherwise
the right to be forgotten would simply
become
censorship now the laws surrounding
personal data are not yet
mature or unified different countries
tackle this issue in different ways i
mean
europe on the one hand prioritizes the
system's right to privacy
whereas in the united states they steer
in the direction of
free speech and god we still haven't
discussed china which takes a much more
authoritarian government-controlled even
orwellian
path but we'll talk about that in a
different video
for my part i'll leave you with one bit
of advice everything we do online
leaves a trace and our personal data can
be used by pretty much anyone
including businesses advertisers
scammers or even
intelligence agencies 1006 have you got
by martini yet
all i'm saying you need to be cautious
and think about each step you take in
the online jungle
because once something is online it's
practically impossible
to delete it the name is peek bradley
peek and this
is the some sub youtube channel and by
the way it's perfectly safe to leave a
like
comment or even subscribe also i think
[Music]
you